[Music]
didn't you guys you i i have heard this
story before you got high and went to a
fox news oh yeah
mike huckabee has a weekend show on fox
and we thought it would be really funny
to put on suits and eat way too many
weed cookies
and uh go see the show and it turns out
that it's just terrifying
yeah
the experience
the experience of going to fox news on
pot cookies
is i've never been more scared and bored
in my life
it's like it's a two-hour taping it was
longer than that it was like three hours
but it does not surprise me they also
they have a mirror to make the audience
look twice as big so we were also seated
next to a mirror so we could just look
at ourselves being stoned
but also the reason we put on suits was
because we were afraid they were gonna
like we weren't gonna fit in we were
like we had to dress like republicans
and so we put on suits and then everyone
else you made that decision sober or
afternoon
no that was that was sober i was like we
gotta wear something that seems like
such a high thought like they'll know
we're not republicans yeah don't wear a
tie
that's not a necessary thing everyone
else is wearing like sweatpants yeah
it's like hawaiian shirts right a lot of
hawaiian shirts a lot of like chinese
tourists we didn't know why they were in
this room
it was great also the guest host that
day interestingly enough uh was rita
ruttner for no reason that's what
happened what happened was uh we were
they put us on the front row and this
show started and
like these dapper gentlemen yes these
guys look great they do have demon red
eyes
well that only makes you look more like
yeah that's right
and so political
take it so
uh
mike huckabee walked out in front of us
and we both uh cracked up like just
immediately he starts off playing his
base with the little rockers which is
his house band so he's playing like
mustang sally we're cracking up
uh because we don't know it's going to
be a two-hour thing with rita right now
uh you don't know how to pace yourself
no exactly it's gonna get better yeah
rudner walked out and i started crying
yeah i was laughing so i'm weeping
noah was also drunk yeah i left you in
line because i was afraid that i got too
high and i wanted to level it out so i
went i went to a bar across the street
came in in my suit and i was like uh do
you guys have a credit card minimum and
they were like yeah and i said how much
and they said 15
so then i asked how much a shot of
jamison was and they said eight and i
said perfect got two shots and then paid
in cash and like so i
[Laughter]
i can't imagine
like what they thought was happening
just like this
that was so confusing the weirdest like
a little boy businessman essentially is
what they saw come in also
it was 11 30 in the morning
after asking multiple questions it was
crazy when it comes with demon eyes in
his stomach
yeah it was uh
so then i was like drunk with a headache
and stoned and we had to watch it but
not fun like we
don't eat weed it's not it's never a
good idea like way too long
and like i was freaking out and and then
this camera man came up to me at one
point tapped me on the shoulder and he
bent down and like kind of whispered in
my ear he's like you know i called the
cops right
you should know that that's not what he
said yeah
because i started freaking out i was
like don't don't call the cops there's
no reason to call the cops and then he
uh looked at me terrified scared of me
yeah
and then he repeated he slowly was just
like uh no i said my camera is coming
through here
yeah those aren't even the same syllabus
auditory hallucination
you know i called the cops yeah
so what i i just hear a guy being like
we have to come through here and then
joe being like do we need to go
what's happening
it's so scary uh uh
two gentlemen freaking out
and then we left and we're high for four
more hours because
we went back to my apartment because i
had tevo i dvr'ed the episode of
huckabee we have you are that anyway
yeah it's just a good show so we
we we wanted to see the show we just saw
so we uh we're still high we started
watching huckabee again and even though
we were sitting in the front row they
managed to edit us out of every single
like the camera would pan and then just
stop and break
like zoom up on a chinese tourist and
then come back you know and then right
so the episode ends and then you turn to
me and you said a thing that maybe
changed my life forever i said
you know what that means we were either
so
high and scary-looking that fox news
didn't feel comfortable putting us on
television
or
we were so high that we never even went
to a huge
which might have been
[Music]